I'm joined Now by retired Air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell so Sean Bell this is a
also echoing something that President
Putin has talked about as well isn't it
expanding Russia's Army how concerning
is that yeah that we've always pour over
Putin's speeches very carefully he's
counseled a couple most recently largely
because he seems very worried about the
sort of questions he might get asked but
this was an mod mystery defense event in
uh in Moscow yesterday where he was
primarily talking to his generals but
there was also a few speeches providing
support for the military anything they
needed and it seems to be more focused a
domestic audience but the rhetoric
within that speech was absolutely about
a maximalist approach it was not about
just taking the Donetsk it was about
subjugating Ukraine more widely and
absolutely blaming the west and NATO for
this action the worrying part of the
speech was that the announcement really
that his planning to change defense
policy which was about increasing the
size of the contract down their
professional core of their army from
about 380 000 to just shorter 700 000 uh
soldiers but also there aren't forces
from just over a million to one and a
half million about a 40 increase in size
the justification again was the threat
from NATO uh interesting Russia is in a
recession at the moment so the more
money you put into defense the less
money you've got for domestic issues
which runs a real risk for Putin of
undermining his support domestically but
what Russia is clearly doing is building
the foundations for a much more robust
military in in the future and also he's
mobilizing Russian industry to be able
to generate the tanks the equipment that
goes with that and of course all of this
presents an increased threat to the West
because our defense assumptions are
going to have to change as a result of
that and inevitably that will have
implications for defense spending well
yeah so that's that's his ambition how
practical is it in the short term to
build up the numbers in your army yes I
mean I worry at the moment is that what
effect will this have on the Ukraine war
the harsh reality is that it costs a
great deal of money to put a 40 increase
and it also takes a lot of time you
can't just generate this equipment
overnight you can't just nip down to the
shops and buy a few more tanks you have
to mobilize industry to get it sorted
clothing ammunition just recruiting
people and training them so we're
talking about years not weeks and it's
very unlikely to have any impact in the
near term on the war itself but what is
quite clear is where Putin's intent is
for the future and therefore he's trying
to buy himself time because the longer
he can pause the longer he he's got he
can generate these military capability
and also erode the support of the West
as they go on so in the near term as
Putin tries to generate this time he may
seem a seek to negotiate but almost
certainly without any intent at all and
what's really interesting the pressures
on Putin he's trying to
um he's doing military training across
in Belarus at the moment well Belarus
used to be a very Junior partner but as
we're seeing some of the Russian forces
here in Belarus
um yet Russia is becoming increasingly
reliant on Belarus it's becoming a
reliant on Iran for providing military
missiles and for um for the drones and
likewise on China and India for some of
the purchasing some of the oil so it
just shows the import increasing
importance on the Diplomatic side that
the West needs to be unified to try to
isolate Russia in that Global Community
okay Sean Bell very interesting thanks
very much indeed